adrien cas tonneins un député de la
france insoumise bonjour merci d'être
avec nous alors comment ce que vous avez
accueilli cette stratégie de
déconfinement à partir du 11 mai je
crois que les français attendent et des
perspectives pour pouvoir se projeter
sur l'après 11 mai et ce qu'ils auront
appris du discours d'edouard philippe
c'est que le 11 mai ce n'était pas des
confinement des français celle des
confinement du travail tout simplement
on voit bien dans le discours qui a été
prononcé hier que selon la nature des
activités auxquelles vous avez
l'intention de vous adonner
vous pourrez prendre des risques qui
sont quand même somme toute assez
variable par exemple s'agissant de la
vie sociale et je pense que tout le
monde en ait assez impatient ce sera
limité à 10 pour un rassemblement le la
pratique de ce sport en collectif sera
impossible mais vous pourrez évidemment
bien sûr d'ailleurs le but est celui ci
prendre les transports en commun pour
vous rendre au travail
on voit bien cette date du 11 mai en
quelque sorte a été choisi
arbitrairement par emmanuel macron avec
une seule perspective
en réalité la reprise de l'activité
économique sur fond de compétition
internationale sans d'ailleurs
s'interroger sur le fait de savoir si
cette mise à l'arrêt de notre économie
en tout cas de deux pans entiers de
notre économie n'est pas aussi
l'occasion d'opérer de grande
différenciation qui sont à mettre à
l'ordre du jour n'en emmanuel macron lui
son style baissé après la crise tout
doit être comme auparavant en tout cas
c'est son point de vue et celle d'al 12
mai qu'il a choisi seul et en
s'exonérant mam a priori sur bien des
aspects de la vie du conseil
scientifique donc pour une fois il ne
s'est pas réclamé lors de son dan sa
dernière allocution présidentielle
cette date du 11 mai apparaissait hier
comme un boulet qui traîne au pied les
noirs philippe qui a bien du mal à
établir un plan qui permet de s'assurer
que tous les moyens sont disponibles le
11 mai pour procéder à ce déconfinement
d'ailleurs il a pris mille précautions
d'usagé dans son discours on l'a bien vu
il a aussi insisté sur ce choix
extrêmement difficile compliquée entre
sauver l'économie sauver les français
sur ce point il a il a tranché puisque
il a précisé que c'était la santé des
français qui étaient évidemment
prioritaire et vous remettez en cause
la date du 11 mai vous dites que c'est
un choix arbitraire sur ce re justement
le choix de sauver les français ou
sauver l'économie
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire mon abord
dire une chose c'est que si le virus
continue à circuler et à priori c'est le
cas il ya un certain nombre de critères
pour pouvoir jauger une stratégie de
déconfinement est ce que une part
importante de la population a été
immunisée la réponse est notre d'autant
plus que pour l'instant vous le savez il
ya encore des controverses sur le fait
de savoir si quand vous avez été
infectés une fois vous êtes protégé pour
une seconde infraction ça n'est pas sur
les traitements et vaccins ne sont pas
encore disponibles
donc à partir de la méfiance prudence
est donc si la priorité est la santé et
c'est notre souci est bien la date à
partir de laquelle on peut d confiné
doit en quelque sorte être non pas le
prendre des parts mais le résultat d'un
processus de quoi avons nous besoin en
quelle quantité
les masques les tests qu'elle
réquisitions nationalisation faut-il
faire
comment organiser tout ça les procédures
de travail également pour les salariés
qui vont reprendre l'activité
directement sur site et ensuite on fixe
une date là on a vraiment ce sentiment
que dans la mesure où se rejoue la
compétition à l'échelle européenne avec
des pays qui sont en train de se tirer
la bourre pour savoir qui reprendra
l'activité le premier est bien emmanuel
macron a posé cette date du 11 mai alors
après vous dites la relance de
l'activité économique moi je veux bien
mais la question devrait être posée de
savoir quelle machine nous voulons
lancer quel type d'activité économique
voulons nous relancer parce qu'il faut
prendre un peu de recul et de
philosophie sur ce qui nous arrive tout
de même il ya quelques années cela vous
en souvenez on faisait face à une crise
économique c'était il ya douze ans
et à l'issue de cette crise économique
cette crise financière le président de
la république de l'époque nicolas
sarkozy dans un discours tout à fait
admirable par ailleurs nous disait c'est
la fin du capitalisme financiarisé il
faut arrêter avec ça quelles leçons ont
été tirées de cette période rien tout a
repris comme avant et moi elle jette
jure que tout ne reprennent pas comme
avant oui il faut une perspective de
déconfinement oui il faut que la vie
reprenne son cours mais nous aurons
d'autres défis à l'avenir à affronter et
la crise que nous vivons aujourd'hui est
l'échec d'un certain modèle de ceux qui
ont préféré le libre marché à l'état de
ceux qui ont préféré le grand
déménagement du monde à la
relocalisation de l'activité de ceux qui
ont préféré
la compétition généralisée de chacun
contre tous à des cadres de coopération
nous ne faisons pas simplement face à un
virus nous faisons face aux effets d'un
virus sur un modèle économique et
politique qui nous a mis en situation de
fragilité et de lune et réhabilité et ça
je regrette qu emmanuel macron ne
l'entendent pas je l'aï entendu comme
vous récemment de dire on a fait des
choses formidables pendant trois ans
nous faisons face à une crise après la
crise on recommence sur les mêmes maps
les mêmes bases que tu as soon as vrai
et ça on n'aura pas à tirer les bonnes
conclusions pour revenir à la date du 11
mai edouard philippe après des
engagements en ce qui concerne les tests
en ce qui concerne les masques vous
remettez en cause ses engagements penser
qu'on ne sera pas prêt le 11 mai des
franchement je ne serai pas réjoui qu'on
ne le soit pas je souhaite comme tous
les français qu'on le soir venu depuis
le début on est pour eux l'unité
d'action s'est pas uni s'est pas l'union
nationale parce que les désaccords
politiques persistent mais le fait en
tout cas l'espérer que la bataille
contre ce virus soit gagner mais pour
nous je les dis la stratégie doit être
planifié raison pour laquelle par
exemple nous avons déposé la clarence
insoumise lundi sur notre plateforme que
tout le monde peut aller visiter un plan
complet de déconfinement selon nous
comment nous y prendre riom si nous
étions en situation de gouverner ce pays
sur la production des masses sur la
production des tests sur les
réquisitions nationalisation de
certaines entreprises
tout ce qu'il convient de faire et je je
je crains et je crois que je ne suis pas
le seul intervenant juste avant moi le
disais aussi je crains que le 11 mai
dans les conditions telles qu'elles ont
été résumées par edouard philippe hier
on peut effectivement craindre que nous
ne soyons pas prêts dans tous les
secteurs que toutes les protections ne
soit pas disponible
je le souhaite de tout coeur mais très
franchement je considère que ce choix
est hasardeux et donc c'est aussi eu
notre devoir que de mettre en garde une
réaction tacle d'edouard philippe hier
vis-à-vis de l'opposition là une phrase
je laisse je le cite la modernité a
souvent fait passer certains députés du
café du commerce à des plateaux de
télévision les courbes d'audience y
gagne ce que la convivialité des
bistrots il perd mais je ne crois pas
que cela grandissent le débat public est
ce que vous vous sentez concerné comment
vous réagissez ce tacle jeu c'est une
bonne formule veut dire et loire
philippe est assez bon orateur et pour
écrire des bonnes formules tout le monde
enfin peut le faire c'est pas le souci
mais je voudrais pas qu'on belle
d'un revers de la main le travail des
politiques y compris l'opposition
politique voyez depuis le début de cette
crise la france en sont mises avec les
moyens qui sont les siens et qui ne sont
pas les moyens de l'état
je ne dispose pas avec mes camarades
d'un conseil scientifique à mon service
pour prendre des décisions mais
néanmoins je demande à ce qu'on allait
voir le travail que nous avons fourni
par exemple se plante déconfinement que
nous avons proposé les onze mesures
d'urgence que nous avons posées sur la
table dès le début de la crise je crois
que nous faisons un travail sérieux et
qui est aussi utile pour contribuer dans
cette situation et voyez-vous le fait
que le débat parlementaire été expédiés
de la sorte qu'on nous demande qu'on la
vence d'une semaine et qu'on nous
demande de prendre connaissance d'un
plan en même temps que tous les français
à 15 heures pour le voter à 18 heures
avec en gros un choix qui est de l'ordre
du à prendre ou à laisser
alors que nous avons fait un travail
complet qui méritaient aussi d'être
débattues discutées peut-être d'enrichir
le plan du gouvernement fera que la
démocratie doit pas être confinée dans
une période comme celle là et que
malheureusement une nouvelle fois le
parlement est là comment faire valoir
qu'ils devraient juste tamponné d'un
saut les desiderata du président de la
république
non ça n'est pas possible et le
président de la république d'ailleurs
n'est pas bien protégé dans la sphère
s'il croit que il va simplement pouvoir
se contenter de faire sauter le fusible
edouard philippe
comme on l'entend parfois pour se
protéger je crois vraiment qu'ils se
trompent tout le monde a bien compris
que la décision du 11 mai sans
planification était bien de tous et
merci beaucoup adrien katana
je rappelle que vous êtes député de la
france un sommier mercière